[Music]
Thank You MIT I'm hugely honored to be
here it's always been a dream of mine to
visit the most prestigious School in
Cambridge Massachusetts hold on a second
certainly the most prestigious school in
this part of Cambridge Massachusetts and
I'll probably be here for a while I
understand a bunch of engineering
students put my motorcade on top of
building 10 this tell you something
about MIT everybody hands out periodic
tables what's up with that dr. Moniz is
also the director of mi t--'s energy
initiative called mighty and he and
president Hockfield just showed me some
of the extraordinary energy research
being conducted at this institute
windows that generate electricity by
directing light to solar cells
lightweight high powered batteries that
aren't built but are grown
Michelle were able to reprogram since
and they're producing batteries
that was neat stuff engineering viruses
to create batteries more efficient
lighting systems that rely on
nanotechnology innovative engineering
that will make it possible for offshore
wind power plants to deliver electricity
even when the air is still you just get
excited to being here and seeing these
extraordinary young people and the
extraordinary leadership of Professor
Hawk field because it taps into
something essential about America it's
the legacy of daring men and women who
put their talents and their efforts into
the pursuit of discovery and it's the
legacy of a nation that supported those
intrepid few willing to take risks on an
idea that might fail but might also
change the world